[Music]
how did it learn that
maybe some latter day dave frankenstein
will build something like that but i
don't think it's a threat
but i do fear the uncritical acceptance
of ai and machine learning in a in a
huge crowd it can pick out
any individual and read that person's
emotional state as you can see here
nothing is off limits
[Music]
i mean with the question is is can are
intelligent
machines a threat you see i have a
problem with the question because
i certainly don't think well that my
definition of a machine
basically it would be a
computer-controlled robot or something
like that
and my position for various reasons is
that
such devices would not be intelligent so
we don't have intelligent machines
and on this criterion we'll never have
them we might have devices
if they i'm not saying that you couldn't
have
a device of some kind which could be
conscious would
which could perhaps achieve uh i'm not
saying we couldn't have a machine which
could be conscious
and could perhaps achieve things of
intelligence that we can do
i'm just saying that they won't be
computer-controlled devices
but computers as such wouldn't have
intelligence
and the kind of reason i would have for
saying this
is that computers well they are by
definition computers
and they do what are called computations
and these
notions of computations or algorithms
were
put forward very clearly by alan turing
and other logicians
and uh there are also strong arguments
that
logicians such as turing i may say and
godel
they put forward arguments which
basically tell us that
understanding is not something that a
computational device is capable of
now the way i look at it is that
understanding is indeed something that
computational device can't do
and understanding is something that
requires
consciousness and consciousness is
something we don't understand yet
it's something which i think there is
strong reason to believe
is not a product of computational action
there's something quite different going
on and we see both things
in the brain and we don't see it we
believe
and have evidence for the part of the
brain
which is back here not the cerebrum
which
i'm talking about the cerebellum which
has about half as many neurons
a half as many which is quite a lot as
the cerebrum has
it has far more interconnections between
these neurons
and it appear apparently is completely
unconscious
and actions you may learn to do
something play the piano play tennis or
something like this
and then when you the skills are
developed your
cerebral cerebellum takes over and
allows you to
do the more sophisticated overall things
what strategy you will use what kind of
feeling will you put into your playing
and that kind of thing whereas the
mechanics of it all is taken over by
entirely unconscious activity now i can
quite accept
that the action of the cerebellum could
be
maybe mimicked by a computer uh there
are lots of things
probably in neural and
neuroscience which is which is
adequately describable by
computational device but whatever
consciousness is is something quite
different
and it's something extremely important
if it weren't important in our actions
it wouldn't have evolved so it's evolved
for some reason
and this reason gives us qualities which
we can
allow us to do things that we can't do
purely consciously
purely unconsciously and it also has
something to do with setting up the
unconscious device
it's a bit like the way computers work
how does a computer
not how it works but how how do we use
the computer we use a computer
you have some idea you have some thing
you wanted to do
you can reduce it to a calculation of
some kind put it on the machine
it does the calculation calculation the
answer comes out and then you
decide what that calculation means the
meaning is not something which is part
of the calculation
it's external to the calculation so
the claim i would make is that we don't
have intelligent machines not only that
we'll never have machines which are
genuinely intelligent
if machine means what i'm saying it
means a computationally controlled
device we might have things
which somehow maybe we'll figure out
what's going on in there and maybe we'll
have
some kind of device which does it i mean
i don't think see it's anywhere within
uh what we can
envisage at the moment maybe some latter
day dave
frankenstein will build something like
that but i don't think it's a threat
to us
[Music]
i agree with hillary obviously that uh
the success
of so-called ai is within a very narrow
domain
because there they can surpass the best
humans essentially because of the speed
once they operate
uh they can do in a few minutes what
a human player would take a year to work
through so
that's a success um but the main point
is that in a wider domain
there are really two problems uh one is
uh that
we don't have good enough sensors so
they can sense the world
now that's the problem getting a
driverless car um but also does the
other point
which is concerned with giving them
common sense uh
for which they need to actually observe
human beings and the problem here
is that uh they uh operate so much
faster
that uh for them watching us
it's like us was watching trees grow
it's very very slow
and this is a big problem of uh uh
making
uh a machine which has ordinary human
common sense
because they can't learn by watching
real human beings
because the data flow into them is far
too low so
that's an inherent problem but uh until
that happens
then we will have this very limited
domain which they can work and uh just
to give a
a simple example of this i i believe it
was the uh
the watson computer that uh won the game
of jeopardy
which was asked which is bigger a
shoebox or mount everest
and couldn't answer and that's because
although it knew everything in wikipedia
it clearly has no sort of concept
of of the physical real world and the
scale of things
so it's going to be very very hard to uh
uh fill up that gap essentially because
uh what things do happen in the real
world are very very slow
compared to the way the machine process
the data
and its advantage over us is speed and
nothing else
if you uh import ai into our present
world with those deficiencies
and inequalities it's not obvious it's
going to make things better
it's going to aggravate some problems
but i still think that
just as we could with our present
knowledge make
a much better and fairer world uh better
health care
in africa and all that sort of thing
ditto with the ai
it would allow us to improve uh the
world and uh
uh replace uh boring jobs um
uh which is a good thing provided that
the money earned by the robots
is used to uh uh raise the pay in the
jobs where you need human beings i'm
saying um
carers bus drivers and things like that
so
it could improve the world with
redistribution
um but of course uh there is the
question of whether
there are just a few very powerful
machines
which somehow are dominant which have
all the information about us
etc and how they use it this is a
genuine question um
and i think uh if you ask me what my
worry is
um it's not so much the misuse
of this but the vulnerability if we
depend on
the complicated machine because i think
the the worry that
it will simply break down or you know
cyber attack on the electricity grid
uh will uh destroy all computer power in
a whole continent or something like that
we are more vulnerable the more we
depend on machines like this but on the
other hand
i think we can genuinely hope that if we
can control them
then they will allow us to uh do
things like control routine things like
controlling traffic and electricity
grids in an optimum way
and monitoring health etc which will be
an improvement but the way it affects
the average person
will as with any other innovation depend
on
how society's organized and how the
benefits are distributed
so i don't think we should demonize ai
it's in the same league as any advance
in health technology for instance
[Music]
okay so yeah i think there's a lot of
this centers around semantics here so
artificial intelligence if we're talking
about intelligence in the form of
consciousness and sentence of course
that we don't have that we may never
have that
i'm quite agnostic and whether we'll
ever have that and if we do it might not
look like our intelligence
but we do have ai around us already in
the form of machine learning which is a
subset it's generally considered a
subset of artificial intelligence
where you can take vast amounts of data
and look for patterns in that data
and use those patterns to predict what
might happen next or to predict the next
in the series or a set
and we already know that it's around us
we if we use a voice assistant for
example
to you know turn up the volume on the
radio if we use google maps
say to plot a route from london to
durham
you know anything like that involves
using ai um
to to critical information to sift
through it and give us a solution so we
do have it
it's in many ways it's a really really
beneficial thing
so we've seen the use of machine
learning for example
in things like medicine where we can
have better rates of tumor detection
um where we are seeing life-saving
diagnoses happening because of the
amount of computing power given to us by
machine learning
but we also have problems when it comes
to
hi this is being used because the data
is problematic in that we're seeing more
and more cases where
data is flawed um it's not
representative
and it's causing bias in the output and
so we have
artificial intelligence machine learning
that discriminates
um not because it's itself in some way
is discriminating but because we're
giving it information that is incorrect
or in some way biased
so we have this problem in that we have
to be more careful of the
technology and analyze it more so are we
going to ever have
conscious machines that at this point it
doesn't really matter i think i don't
i don't fear some singularity happening
anytime soon but i
do fear the uncritical acceptance of
ai and machine learning and we need to
look much more wider
widely and much more ethically at the
way that ai is being developed today
now there have been several ai winters
what's known as ai winters along the
course of development from the 50s
onwards so we saw
sort of uh initially um enthusiasm for
ai was very very good
um but when it didn't deliver properly
in the 70s it was ai winter where
the government pulled funding and
nothing really happened for a while and
again it happened in the 80s there was
some promise of advances and then it
collapsed again
and now we're very possibly heading into
another ai winter
we've gone quite far with deep learning
for example getting lots of results but
we're starting to see the flaws and the
limitations
and people are getting more critical of
those so
how it goes in the next few years is
going to be very very interesting indeed
so the last um five to ten years
as as you've seen in the in the media
and elsewhere
um and for those working in the field
you're at the forefront of this
uh there's been great progress in ai
and there's been a very serious
dedication
to drawing on psychology and
neuroscience to build ai
that do model intelligence so not just
machines that seem to do things
intelligently
uh like watson or deep blue but but do
it in a way that um
isn't truly intelligent but actually
understanding the brain and trying to
build a machine that that thinks like we
do
things like humans do so here's an
example of a paper
that makes this case neuroscience
inspired artificial intelligence
so and this paper again has
people from deepmind but uh deepmind is
again not not
at all alone in this there's money going
into centers all over the world
in china south korea the united states
with this initiative of building ai that
has human-like intelligence
um and it's not just going one way it's
not just from neuroscience cognitive
science our understanding of humans and
animals to
machines but there's also an interest in
looking at what machines can teach us
about humans and animals
so in in this paper that i just showed
you the authors say
distilling intelligence into an
algorithmic construct and comparing it
to the human brain
might yield in insights into some of the
deepest and most enduring mysteries of
the mind
such as the nature of creativity dreams
and perhaps
one day even consciousness
so as you can see here um nothing is off
limits
in in ai research and there's this
optimism
that not only can we build machines that
have these capacities that have
imagination
that have theory of mind that have
creativity but
that we can understand what's going on
when we're being creative
by taking what we've learned about the
machines
and applying it to us
and in the second part of this
course i will specifically look at the
case of alphago
alphago is a great test case for looking
at whether machines can be creative
because it has been described as having
creative intuition
and the game that it has mastered go is
a game that was thought to require
creative intuition to master
just to give you a few quotes to prime
you for why
that alphago is very interesting in what
it's doing
um one of the things that a software
engineer and professional go player
have said in describing alphago they say
and this is to show you that alphago
maybe we should think about it as
creative
unlike perhaps other programs in the
past
so they say alphago's strategy embodies
a spirit of flexibility
and open-mindedness a lack of
preconceptions that allows it to find
the most effective line of play
so flexibility and open-mindedness that
sounds like
something we would require from a
creative
machine and not only that
but here you have lisa doll who's um the
top one of the top players in the world
says what surprised me the most
was that alphago showed us that moves in
the game of go
uh moves humans may have thought were
our creative
we're actually conventional i think this
will bring a new paradigm
to go so it's not just that alpha goes
itself playing creatively but it's
showing us that maybe humans aren't as
creative as we thought we were
so we'll again talk about um that
um in the second part but i just want to
go back to colossus and say
well maybe that's not so you know again
try to
suggest that it's not that far in the
future that we might have something like
colossus
here's an example of
a data produced by alpha fold
where deepmind said that and this is
again another product of deep mind as
you can tell from
the name alpha fold so what this uh
network has done is predicted the
structures that proteins take um so
proteins are encoded from genetic
material
but it's hard to predict how those
proteins will
once they're folded up what
configuration they will end up in
uh and this is you know very important
scientific work uh that's being done
by humans trying to figure out what the
configurations are and how they might
change
and it's important because of various
there are many disorders that
involve a misconfiguration of a protein
and so they've here have had a program
that can predict the the structure uh
in in ways that excel humans and in some
cases
so uh that the goal is to produce ai
that can make
um scientific discoveries and that is
where
a lot of people are
focusing on uh developing ai
okay so now now that we've said all that
so i produced i i gave kind of the
philosophical
definitions of creativity but then we
backed up
and said well there are all these other
disciplines that seem to
not really fit with that definition and
i do
think that it's important to take all
these disciplinary views into account
[Music]
and why do we have to talk about ai well
several reasons the one is because
um if you don't the conversation
is going to be had by a lot of techy
boys
who are billionaires who are going to
decide what the future is because they
know better than you
and having interviewed them they really
think this
uh so it's a kind of conversation where
you need to get involved now
because otherwise they'll have built it
and they'll be too late
they like to talk about ai for everyone
but when they say things like well ai
will do things for you
well it will but mostly it'll do things
to you
and we all you can see that you know
facial recognition
is coming and there's a company
i can't tell you its name because i get
in trouble um chatting for work in the
uk
and what they say is rai can
identify in a in a huge crowd it can
pick out
any individual and read that person's
emotional state you think okay
their strapline is we will be able to
tell if someone
is in an emotionally heightened
potentially dangerous
emotional state and get security to
intervene before they do something
how do you feel about that
that's slightly dodgy isn't it slightly
yeah slightly
but in what way can people respond to
that
well you could say to your politicians
wake the hell up
because at the moment the politicians
are doing nothing i mean there are a
couple of sort of
ineffectual not quite buffoons but just
intellect
they're just people who are marvelous
some
very clever chaps came around and told
me it's going to be marvelous and it'll
be great
it'll be beneficial for everyone and
they're the gatekeepers then the people
are looking after things for you
so if you leave it to them you're sunk
but you still believe that
politics sort of has control of tech
companies i don't think it does at the
moment no
i agree with you it doesn't but it will
need to
um and
the other reason i've been apart from
that practical reason is because
what ai will be able to do
poses really deep philosophical
questions for us
i mean the one that i asked lots of them
about is
what is it you want from ai
i mean what do you want when you think
ai
and when you ask people enough
what they want is something that will do
all of the stuff for them it'll
make the bed it'll make a cake it'll
figure out how to get the cheapest
flight
and we're talking about ai which even if
it isn't conscious
will be like being conscious
you know those have got those little
google boxes you can speak to
and in the end you end up with something
that's
almost a slave
it will do everything you want to do it
can't say no you can be as rude to it as
you like
and you think yeah but it's it's a it's
a machine it's it's it's not
it's not you're not really enslaving it
it's a machine
but how would you feel about your child
growing up
interacting with the machine like that
it's my worry is not that we harm the
machines
i wonder what it does to us
our moral fiber if if you live in a
world where you have a machine that's
sort of like
human and you treat it like a slave
did you get the sense though that it was
a thought out sort of value-led or
you know philosophical viewpoint they
had or it was
just sort of a technology for
technology's sake they were interested
in the progress of the technology rather
than sort of how it drives forward what
it's massively yeah
i mean that's one of the questions isn't
it and the answer was some of them will
talk to you about
um um i'll give you some examples i
can't quote them
word for word or i'll infringe their
copyright so these are paraphrases
and i can't tell you who either
otherwise some lawyer will come and drag
me out by the neck
um but i i asked what a couple of them i
said well
these these machines will have to make
moral choices if you have a if you have
a
an autonomous killing machine and we
have them
it's going to make ethical choices about
is it right
you know if there's a a terrorist that
it wants to kill
but there are 25 children sitting around
do you kill the terrorists and blow up
all the children or don't you
and humans will be out of that loop
we're in the loop at the moment there's
a little switch literally a switch you
can keep humans in the loop
when it comes to a shooting match that
switch gets switched off
because the whole value of ai machines
is that they react faster than humans
so if you keep a human in the loop it's
as slow as humans and you may as well
not have the ai
so there will be really serious ethical
issues or even driving cars you know
do you program the car so that if if
a group of children run out into the
road
do you mow down the children and you
survive or does the car swerve off the
road and
embed you and your brains in a brick
wall
and i said well who who and they said oh
don't worry we're going to put we're
going to program in
values i said well whose values and the
answer was
nice ones okay that's a deep
philosophical
position nice ones
you know i think different cultures will
program in different values
but who's deciding
do you have your own uh ideas of why
this urge sort of outsource
whether it's morality or you know robots
to bring up your kids
why has that become a progression in
which we're seeing yeah well
a lot of people some of the scientists
i can think of one in particular um
their answer is
well humans are so rubbish at this we
are irrational
and we have prejudices and we'll make
and ais won't have these things except
they will
because we they
feed off big data sets of our behavior
so there will be some kind of prejudice
in there
but you won't even be able to argue with
it
i mean there's an ai that's used in
america right now
i think 13 states use it and it's a they
decided that
they would have an ai because it was
more even-handed
to decide which criminals should get
parole
because humans are so pious
and so this thing was making the
decisions this person yes that one gets
paroled this person no go
back to the and an ngo
began to look at this and they actually
went to court and they got to look at
the raw data
and it turns out black americans were 13
times more likely to be denied parole by
the ai
than a white person had exactly the same
crimes
so but there's this notion that
it'll be better because it's a machine
it'll be fair well it won't be
it'll be worse because if you made a
decision i didn't like as a judge
i could i could come and pick at your
chambers and i could
say i want to know why you said that you
can't do that with an ai
because the code is proprietary
it's their private property you're not
allowed to know
and that's another thing that came out
in the particular case i'm talking about
even though they won the case to show
that it was unfair
the company said yeah but you can't find
out why because that's our private
property
so there's a lot of questions which we
need to work through now
and we need to be the ones asking
because the money involved
is depends every company in every
country knows that people who get to the
market
first will own the rest of the world and
putin said it
and he was right and he was at some
panel and said
whichever country cracks general a.i
will rule the world and he wasn't
exaggerating everybody knows it
there are examples of ways in which ai
is helping
us understand what it is to be human any
positive stories coming out
there's lots of positive stories and it
is
it is another way of saying well what is
consciousness and what's the
relationship between consciousness and
self-awareness
and and it's making us understand that
the difference between those two things
and
and the difference between being clever
and being conscious they're not they're
not the same thing i mean
most ais will be zombies you know
like in the zombie films they're really
quick
but there's no nobody home um
so it's doing all those sort of things
there's tremendous good but
i think we'll only realize the good if
if the conversation is had more wisely
otherwise it won't do things for you
it'll do things to you
for someone else's profit it's not a
mystery is it i mean you know
and it is a transformative technology
and
people need to get involved that was
what was fun about doing that project
is
[Music]
well we could spend a long time just
talking about that but instead i thought
i'd talk
today about where the ai which everybody
frets about
is taking us now ai is on our phones the
reason it's on our phones is a simple
proposition
today's ai is tomorrow's computer
science okay
it's a marketing gimmick i'm a professor
of ai
we are nowhere near building a generally
intelligent
machine with self-awareness that doesn't
stop hollywood worrying about it and it
doesn't stop us building remarkable
systems
so i can speak into siri and ask siri to
tell me when michelangelo died or was
born and i will get a response
40 years ago that would have been
remarkable we'd have thought
we in ai had conquered the world at that
point
we are task by task achieving remarkable
things
from the hoovers in your house to the
telly robots for medicine
the late great lamented um stephen
hawking
thought this was such an incredible rate
of development that we had to worry
about the existential threat
of ai rising and putting us out of
business
sadly as we wrote the first edition of
this uh he was alive
and um it went to print three days
before he died
um so he's still alive in he'd be glad
to know but what caulking did he called
out
he called out to us to consider what the
moral hazard
of very smart machines could be i don't
believe
in fact that ai
is a threat to humanity in and of itself
our inappropriate use of the technology
is the threat to humanity
it's now a dual use technology just like
nuclear and chemical and biological
science
has been weaponized we have to think
about that
and of course our hollywood depictions
of ai is full of machines that are mad
bad and dangerous to know
just a very few of them very few of them
are worth getting to know like uh
david in uh in spielberg's ai but or
indeed finally
terminator of course has this redemptive
moment you know he's being
melted down nonsense all nonsense
at this point this is
an example of a neural network learning
to play
breakout initially it knows nothing at
all
about the game at all nothing at all but
it's going to learn
through time to control those paddles
what you'll see in the video
is that the system is useless to start
with
so 10 minutes of training it never gets
anywhere close to the ball
never gets anywhere close to it all it
knows
is that it's getting fed every few
microseconds a
a state of the entire pixel all the
pixels on that screen
and it's trying to work out the
correlation between those pixels
and increasing the score okay that's all
it's trying to do
two hours of training using one of these
latest neural networks and i'll show you
a little bit about
how that looks it can play as you as
well as you and i can
okay two hours it's rather good i mean
you know
i always tended to miss i wasn't that
good
the magic is what happens after more
training so it trains and trains and
trains this is
four hours of training from nothing at
all to
the rather scary sight of a machine that
appears to have learnt
not just how to play the game but how to
play it to a superhuman level
there it is zipping around and what
you'll remember in that game if you
could get the ball behind the barrier
it'd knock them all out right how did
it learn that okay so
that was the set of demonstrations
amongst others that convinced google to
pay 400 million dollars to demise the
seabiss to buy the company
uh i'm not sure he's sure he should ever
sold it in fact in truth but
um wonderful insights wonderful kind of
uh demonstration
and what he demonstrated was the power
of layer on layer on layer of neural
networks so that one i showed you
earlier just had one middle layer
you can now stack up chip on chip on
chip
to actually perform computation across
the connections
across the links to look for the
underlying correlations
in screen after screen after screen
that is equivalent to learning the
control of those paddles to increase the
score
if there's a pattern in there these
systems will find it
so my point here is that we are in a
situation
where we have this kind of arms race
going on the machines
are getting more capable they're getting
extremely powerful in specific areas
and yet despite the protestations of
many i don't believe they're going to be
as i say waking up or indeed taking all
of our jobs we're very very uh
inventive about creating new things for
us to do
the book spends a lot of time reflecting
on these various aspects of what it'd be
like to live
in this new digital reality it tries not
to frighten you to death
it tries to say that we've all got
choices in this
the most important thing we can do is
understand what
the limits and opportunities as well as
the dangers of this technology are
and the significant one isn't the
machines
it's coming to a relationship and a
compact with the great companies that
will own much of this capability
about how we might have said it's not
just how you live
in peace with smart machines it's how we
live in peace
with giant data monopolies as well
because a lot of the control
uh for uh the next generation of ai
will reside with the companies that have
the data that can train the algorithms
to build these very powerful task
achieving ai systems for more debates
talks and interviews subscribe today to
the institute
of art and ideas at iai tv
you